[Música]
tres días en Moscú estará el presidente
de China en una visita que el mundo
entero ha seguido minuto a minuto Muy
atento todo el mundo a cada palabra
declaración o comentario que pueda salir
de este encuentro por qué tanta atención
china juega un papel fundamental en la
coyuntura internacional que está
enmarcada justamente en la guerra en
Ucrania y las sanciones occidentales
hacia Rusia en ese intento de cerco que
buscan sofocar al presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin es ahí donde china
empieza a jugar un rol clave por ser un
Aliado O tal vez un rival estratégico en
esta ecuación miremos algunos de los
datos Esta visita de tres días al
kremlin tiene varios puntos clave el
primero hablar de la guerra que Rusia
está librando en el este de Ucrania
también Busca que China y Rusia
fortalezcan su posición conjunta frente
a las potencias occidentales es decir
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
también ambos países buscan mejorar el
ya lucrativo intercambio comercial de
ahí ese acuerdo para la construcción de
un nuevo gasoducto que lleve petróleo y
gas y otros derivados de hidrocarburos
desde Rusia hasta china en este caso
específico sería suministro de gas en el
contexto actual china ha invitado ha
evitado condenar la invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania ha defendido la soberanía
territorial de ambos países pero el
mundo Aún se pregunta si Beijing
simpatiza o no con las reivindicaciones
de Rusia que llevaron a que este país
invadiera a Ucrania y desatar una guerra
allí sin embargo y como pocas veces ha
actuado china propuso un plan de un plan
de paz de 12 puntos es gestor de paz es
hasta tal vez una nueva faceta que está
teniendo china como actor internacional
Rusia por su parte dijo que revisará
esta propuesta pero poco entusiasmo se
vio en la cara del presidente Putin
frente a este tema pero están las
relaciones entre China y Rusia en un
momento a grandes rasgos Rusia necesita
de China para poder sortear esas
sanciones impuestas que le ha impuesto
la comunidad internacional sobre todo
occidente del otro lado china pues
compra petróleo y gas ruso muy barato
muy buenos precios eso le permite
entonces mantener su gigantesca economía
en marcha en medio de altos precios y
escasez de otra parte Rusia compra todo
tipo de electrodomésticos automóviles y
aparatos de tecnología que son hechos en
China una mina de oro para china sin
embargo este país asiático no puede
dejar de lado los gigantescos mercados
en donde está es decir Estados Unidos y
Europa pero hay algo paradójico en esta
relación tanto china como Rusia buscan
en su forma y en su estilo tener
protagonismo internacional y sobre todo
liderazgo ambos países persiguen lo
mismo y eso los lleva a chocar en
escenarios comunes como por ejemplo en
las áreas de influencia por ejemplo en
Asia central entonces china ya ha
llegado pisando muy fuerte de algunos
países han preferido tener una relación
con china en vez de Rusia que
históricamente era el país fuerte en esa
zona Lo mismo sucede en África y en
América Latina donde los dos buscan
posicionarse en África específicamente
china ya está muy bien parada tanto
Rusia como china son integrantes de Los
brics y disputan digamos que de manera
implícita el liderazgo en este bloque
económico así las cosas esta amistad que
qué tanto puede durar puede ser cuando
los intereses de uno sobrepasen los
intereses del otro o las necesidades de
uno sobrepasen las necesidades del otro
podrán ambos países establecer ese mundo
multipolar justo Pero a qué se refiere
Moscú y Beijing cuando están hablando de
justo es justo o bajo los términos que
ellos prefieren la relación entre China
y Rusia tiene un toque de
simbolismo es paradójica pero sobre todo
es un gran dilema tanto para ellos como
para el mundo entero por eso lo vamos a
analizar hoy en el debate de France 24 y
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Raquel y Samara ella es phd
en Asia y en estudios de China también
es profesora e investigadora de negocios
internacionales de la Universidad
Autónoma de Puebla también es directora
del observatorio de la política china ya
se encuentra justamente en la ciudad de
Puebla en México y desde la ciudad de
Buenos Aires en Argentina se conecta
Andrés servín él Es doctor en ciencias
políticas y analista internacional
presidente de latín Tank regional Cris
también es autor de varios textos por
ejemplo euroasia y América Latina en un
mundo multipolar también les recuerdo
que nuestros televidentes ustedes los
que están sintonizando France 24 y el
debate hasta ahora hacen parte de este
diálogo de esta conversación pueden
dejar sus preguntas a través de las
redes sociales por ejemplo en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram allí no se
encuentran como arroba franz24- bajo es
la etiqueta numeral del debate f-24 mi
cuenta arroba santilogo para que también
dejen los comentarios por último y para
finalizar todos los programas del debate
ya están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
bueno entramos en materia saludo
entonces a Raquel en la ciudad de Puebla
en México Raquel Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y para comenzar
este encuentro que tiene lugar en Moscú
sirve para afianzar esa relación
Moscú Beijing o para reescribir esa
relación que tienen estos dos países es
una especie Yo podría decirlo como una
especie de salvavidas para el presidente
Putin que análisis hace usted bienvenida
Muchas gracias Santiago bueno en este
caso creo que es una visita que llega en
un timing muy interesante justo después
de que empina ASUME este tercer mandato
creo que es un mensaje muy importante a
la comunidad internacional hecho de que
él viaje a Moscú y comienza a generar
este tipo de dinámicas de alguna forma
bueno la relación siempre ha sido
sumamente importante y en esta
importancia que tiene un aspecto
importante analizar en todo lo que
mencionabas en esta introducción es de
que hoy en día es una relación más
pragmática que en este caso con otro
tipo de ti un tanto más diplomáticos por
todo el contexto que conlleva la la
guerra en Ucrania y sobre todo por estos
elementos económicos que hoy en día para
china se vuelven sumamente importantes
para poder este sostener Este modelo de
desarrollo económico que pues obviamente
con los resultados del año 2022 hoy en
veinte tres es importante reactivar
cualquier tipo de paso cualquier tipo de
industria donde china necesita seguir
creciendo a estos ritmos
opinión de Raquel en la ciudad de Puebla
en México pasó ahora a saludar a Andrés
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires Andrés
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa y la misma pregunta como Punto
de partida esta reunión este encuentro
de tres días en Moscú sirve para
afianzar esa relación o para reescribir
comenzar un nuevo capítulo o simplemente
para lanzar un salvavidas al presidente
Putin en la coyuntura en la que está
bienvenido Muchas gracias Santiago
siempre un placer participar en el
debate
Yo diría que quizás debamos enfocar un
poco desde otro ángulo que es lo que
está pasando en la relación china Rusia
porque no es una relación que se produce
a raíz de la situación en Ucrania es una
situación que se viene de una relación
que se viene desarrollando prácticamente
desde hace más de dos décadas desde la
firma del tratado de amistad y
solidaridad entre bellísimo y Moscú en
el 2001 y que he ido construyéndose
progresivamente en función de un
liderazgo que yo diría que es casi en
tándem en el ámbito de euroasiático y
que ha generado
institucional muy importante como la
organización de cooperación de Shanghai
como el proceso de armonización entre la
franja y la ruta la iniciativa de la
franja y la ruta por parte de China y la
unión económica euroasiática por parte
de Rusia y toda la serie de elementos
que han ido configurando el espacio
euroasiático en donde desde luego el
liderazgo podemos disputar Hasta qué
punto uno es más protagónico que otro
pero el liderazgo prácticamente
compartido con una división del trabajo
yo diría Hasta cierto punto porque hay
una vieja frase con respecto a esta
competencia que se plantea muchas veces
a los ojos occidentales en el ámbito de
Gracia central entre China y Rusia en
donde en realidad china es el bolsillo y
Rusia es el cañón como diría la frase
simplificando la situación y esto Esto
es importante porque ha habido
suficiente coordinación para avanzar en
las iniciativas que ya mencioné Pero
además la iniciativa de los bricks donde
también los que están liderando son
Rusia y China fundamentalmente
lo demás un triángulo estratégico muy
importante en el ámbito grasiático que
es la relación con primero con la India
y la India se incorpora la organización
de cooperación de shanghá entre otros
elementos y según ahora una relación
triangular también con Irán en donde
Irán se ha incorporado la unión
económica de asiática probablemente todo
este esta cantidad de siglas pero es
importante entender que este es un
proceso en construcción el de la
relación entre China y Rusia que se
viene desarrollando a lo largo de dos
décadas ahora frente a la situación de
Ucrania desde luego podemos empezar a
matizar cómo se comporta cada uno de los
actores ya sabemos
y de China fundamentalmente lo que hay
que tener en cuenta yo ahí concuerdo con
lo que acaba de decir mi colega en
cuanto a su aspiración al desarrollo y a
la proyección internacional para lo cual
sí necesita de socio a Rusia bueno
Comencemos entonces analizando el papel
de china Y tratar de entender porque
china no ha sido lo suficientemente
Clara en
en contarle a la comunidad internacional
si respalda o no esos reclamos que tiene
Rusia como justificación para esta
invasión y para desatar este conflicto
en Ucrania porque china no ha tomado
ningún tipo de posición comienzo con
Raquel
OK Bueno sobre este punto primero hay
que recordar que siempre la política
exterior China tiene una serie de
elementos que que la caracterizan y uno
de ellas es esta búsqueda constante de
una buena imagen a nivel internacional
no poco a poco retomando Un poco lo que
decía Andrés también la política
exterior china se va construyendo y ahí
ha ido evolucionando y los últimos años
digamos ya hacia esta segunda parte de
de esta década del veinte china ha
comenzado a tener esta este mayor
protagonismo en la parte de la
gobernanza global no en la cual de
alguna forma lo que se busca es este en
este discurso de un trato más justo es
comenzar a a proponer instituciones a
generar un mayor digamos punto de vista
chino dentro de la gobernanza global y
en ese sentido es de que se cuida mucho
el discurso chino por parte tanto del
presidente como también del Ministerio
de relaciones exteriores donde por un
lado no puede visible el hecho de decir
que no está de acuerdo con lo que haga
Rusia Pero por otro lado no puede ir en
contra digamos de la gobernanza global
tal cual principalmente en este motivo
importante que es la construcción de paz
sobre todo por todos los ejercicios de
cooperación de seguridad que se están
manejando hoy en día donde obviamente ya
hablaban ahorita de este corredor
euroasiático que es sumamente es
sumamente importante no solamente a
nivel seguridad sino también a nivel
energético sino también esta esta nueva
posicionamiento a la política exterior
de Estados Unidos principalmente con el
discurso del Indo Pacífico que cada vez
toma Más fuerza a través del famoso quad
no donde en lo personal yo Considero que
en esta cuestión de liderazgo de los
brics no debemos dejar de lado a India
sobre todo por este tipo de protagonismo
que es bien impulsando desde el 2014
Estados Unidos respecto a Cómo hacer un
contrapeso a China y Andrés Cuál es su
opinión porque china no no respalda o sí
o no Porque no lo tenemos claro esos
reclamos de Rusia respaldar Rusia en
otros escenarios sobre todo en el
comercial como ustedes lo han mencionado
pero en este caso en este caso
específico de la Guerra de Ucrania qué
posición tiene China
bueno primero que tenemos que tener en
cuenta que en general la política
exterior china en función de esta
aspiración a hacer un protagonista
global es una política extremadamente
cautelosa se mide muy bien y no se
apresura y en ese sentido por un lado
está todo lo que yo señalaba de la
construcción de la relación entre los
dos países
que necesariamente los acerca cada vez
más y en este contexto puede haber
matices en cuanto a cómo se ASUME una
posición de apoyo o no apoyo a Rusia
pero no nos olvidemos que no es
solamente china es una cantidad de otros
países que también han asumido una
oposición particularmente lo que
respecta a las sanciones con respecto a
Rusia que algunos pueden llamar de no
alineamiento en el caso de la India por
ejemplo o de neutralidad en otros casos
Entonces yo creo que chile se maneja con
mucha cautela pero a la vez este viaje
muestra y es un símbolo muy importante
debe importancia que china le presta al
vínculo con Rusia y por eso después de
cuatro años tenemos Esta visita de tres
días de muy alto nivel en un contexto de
mucho mucha atención y mucho conflicto
internacional en general y quiero llamar
la atención que es curioso que también
se están produciendo otras cosas
paralelamente que no no son tan
llamativas pareciera para la prensa pero
que también configuran parte de esta
dinámica nueva que se está generando en
el tablero internacional
de Japón visitó la India el día de ayer
y hoy Estaba en
entonces hay un juego de tensión entre
lo que son los socios occidentales los
que son los socios euroasiáticos para
llamarlo de alguna manera o no
occidentales y un grupo de actores
intermedios como es el caso de la India
que recibe Bueno sí tenemos relaciones
con Rusia pero también tenemos
relaciones con occidente estamos en el
quad pero a la vez somos un socio
comercial muy importante con Rusia y
estamos comprando su petróleo a un
precio reducido para revendérselo a
Europa Andrés en este sentido la visita
a Moscú del presidente de China
hace parte de esa carrera entre entre
digamos entre ambos bandos demostrar
quién le da apoyo a quién y quién visita
a quién hemos visto Cuántos presidentes
y primeros ministros han llegado aquí a
darse la mano con el presidente de
Ucrania Polo dimer selensky esto mismo
están tratando de mostrarlo en Moscú
pero son pocos los aliados que está
teniendo Rusia que se animen a hacer
este tipo de visitas oficiales a gran
escala con cubrimiento internacional
aquí Esta visita es puntualmente para
mostrarle apoyo a Rusia o porque China
tiene algún interés en desescalar el
conflicto en Ucrania por el impacto
económico que esto está teniendo que
está repercutiendo justamente en la
parte comercial china Europa que es el
mercado principal por la inflación y los
altos costos que ha llevado la guerra no
puede comprar tantas cosas a China usted
cómo lo ve
yo creo que chile hace tiene un interés
muy especial desde el punto de vista
económico y eso es uno de sus Pilares en
términos de la estrategia de desarrollo
que está promoviendo en cuanto a poder
acceder a toda una serie de mercados
pero a la vez china sí ASUME como
socio importante a Rusia no estamos
hablando de Alianza sino de socios y
esto se manifiesta en otro tema que está
totalmente desplazado por el tema de
Ucrania en este encuentro pero que me
parece muchísimo más importante y es la
configuración de un espacio
desdolarizado en el ámbito no occidental
lo que se va a hablar entre o lo que ya
se habló no sé entre
y Putin es el uso del Joan y de las
monedas nacionales en los intercambios
en el ámbito euroasiático en general y
del proceso de desdolarización
respaldado por el oro Los commodities
Pero además que le dan fuerza
principalmente como moneda nacional al
yuan o
y la prueba más evidente la hemos visto
en la reunión con Arabia Saudita y los
Países Árabes en el Golfo Pérsico por
parte de silvin en donde claramente se
planteó de que pasamos del petróleolar a
algo que pareciera sonar el el Petro
yuán Porque es importante dentro de la
estrategia de China darle relevancia a
las monedas nacionales y en particular
que esto gira en torno al porque ese es
un fundamento de su economía obviamente
Raquel su opinión
sí en este punto yo lo veo desde dos
perspectivas una Estoy totalmente de
acuerdo a lo que menciona Andrés
respecto a esta estrategia geoeconómica
donde ya no solamente hablamos de de
dinámicas de comercio internacional sino
también de posicionamiento a nivel
financiero y más con todo este contexto
digamos de lo que está pasando en la
banca en mercados financieros alrededor
del mundo principalmente en Estados
Unidos y en Europa pero al mismo tiempo
creo que otra lectura de otro tema que
está digamos ligado a toda esta
situación es esta este punto de la
vinculación que pueda llegar a tener
Rusia con china en en la escalada de
tensión en la relación entre Estados
Unidos y China principalmente por el
tema del estrecho de Taiwán donde de
alguna manera los todo lo que ha sido el
inicio del veinte veintitrés ha sido
prácticamente esta digamos este
intercambio de discursos y declaraciones
e incluso de demeritar lo que hace un
lado y el otro respecto incluso a la en
el tema de Ucrania o incluso las
intenciones que se pueda tener china
hacia el resto de la región del Asia
Pacífico no Entonces por ello creo que
son estos dos análisis tanto el Geo
económico pero también el geopolítico y
sobre todo el hecho de cómo hoy en día
en pleno veinte veintitrés pareciera ser
que el el la punta del iceberg hoy en
día es esta cuestión de la cooperación
en seguridad pero también conlleva
muchísimos otros este aspectos en los
cuales hoy en día yo quitando un tanto
el caso de Rusia Estados Unidos y China
comienzan a compartir ciertos espacios
en los que ya son incómodos y que de
alguna forma en función de cómo se va
desdibujando esto dentro del sistema
internacional se comienzan a hacer
visibles una serie de estrategias y
tácticas en las cuales pues obviamente
Esta visita con respecto a Rusia también
afianza otros aspectos no solamente el
económico sino también el tema militar y
de seguridad en ese orden de ideas
Raquel uno entendería y viendo la
posición en la que está Rusia un poco
aislado de la comunidad internacional
sancionado por los países de occidente
Tal parece que china es ese salvavidas
que le puede ayudar económicamente
militarmente Aunque siempre ha negado
Beijing que le da algún tipo de apoyo a
Rusia desde que comenzó la guerra pero
Tal parece que en el escenario digamoslo
en un campo de fútbol la pelota está en
este lado de China está en las manos de
Beijing para modificar esa relación con
Rusia al modo y estilo que ellos la
necesitan justamente como
parte de esta construcción de un
liderazgo internacional porque qué tiene
para ofrecer Rusia Más allá de petróleo
y gas cuando está prácticamente aislado
de la comunidad internacional china
entiende esto
sí creo que en ese sentido Ya lo hemos
dicho a lo largo de las intervenciones
china es un un estado que planea a largo
plazo no y en esa planeación a largo
plazo la relación con respecto a a Rusia
también ha venido evolucionando y en ese
mismo sentido creo que para China si
bien económicamente es ahí donde le
conviene más a China generar esta este
acuerdo de paz Considero que en un largo
plazo lo que más le conviene a a China
es mantener esta vinculación de amistad
con respecto a a Rusia por la
importancia que en próximos años pudiera
llegar a tener este corredor
euroasiático Obviamente con la evolución
del bri Obviamente con la evolución de
la Organización de cooperación Shanghai
y como de alguna forma se comienza a
balancear esta idea del occidente y el
Oriente el respecto a temáticas
económicas a temáticas políticas y que
en este mismo sentido
en lo personal este Considero que el
tema digamos de mantener a una Rusia
aliada es un costo que tiene que ser muy
diplomática China para poder mantenerlo
en ese sentido y por otro lado también
mantener esta buena imagen al exterior
con el resto de de occidente quitando
Estados Unidos y a la Unión Europea
Claro porque no creo yo Andrés que a
Beijing le convenga mantener una
relación con Rusia pero que Rusia sea un
país vencido en este conflicto creo que
le conviene más una Rusia
perdedora y
en cierta forma en crisis para necesitar
aún más de los recursos y en lo que le
pueda suministrar China para mantener
además esta imagen de un país que es el
único Aliado que se le vende el
escenario internacional que un país que
se declare perdedor de este conflicto
que ellos mismos impulsaron o sea aquí
china Así quiera o no está metida ya en
el conflicto de Ucrania y aquí yo creo
que entra en juego esa frase que decían
tanto el Moscú como Beijing que la
amistad entre los dos países era una
amistad sin límites es una amistad sin
límites china se puede dejar arrastrar
por una Rusia vencida
primero sí es una amistad sin límites y
sólida como lo han declarado porque
insisto se ha venido construyendo a lo
largo pero más allá de eso pero pero en
el en el ámbito de Ucrania si Rusia
pierde en la guerra
el problema no yo quiero retroceder un
poco porque algunas cosas que habría que
precisar con más claridad primero Rusia
no es solamente recursos naturales e
hidrocarburos Rusia es un poderío
nuclear y que está por encima de China
Rusia le ha vendido armas a China es una
confusión en esto de la asistencia de
las armas de China Rusia históricamente
ha sido a la inversa y Rusia ha
proporcionado armas a China entonces lo
que hay que tener en cuenta es que los
dos países han sido identificados en el
mapa geopolítico desde la perspectiva de
los documentos de seguridad de Estados
Unidos como un enemigo principal y un
enemigo secundario Pero los dos son
enemigos Entonces en realidad puede ser
que no los una el amor pero los uno del
espanto frente a lo que significa ser
una amenaza considerarse ser considerada
como una amenaza para Estados Unidos y
lo que eso puede implicar en términos de
la reacción de Estados Unidos entonces
la convergencia estratégica china no se
limita a lo que podamos discutir ahora
en relación específica a a Ucrania y yo
creo que el plan de paz Es una buena
iniciativa porque sucede a lo que han
logrado en términos de la relación ir al
área sodio y recientemente los chinos No
pero yo creo que hay que hay que ir más
allá y ver cómo esto se proyecta en
términos de un protagonismo
internacional en donde se reconoce la
actitud de Estos factores relevantes
como parte del sistema internacional no
solamente para recibir la regla de juego
y las normas establecidas por occidente
sino también para incidir en la creación
de nuevas nuevas y de nuevos mecanismos
de gobernanza global incluyendo
particularmente la arquitectura
financiera
Raquel su opinión
Bueno en ese sentido comparto mucho esta
parte no de la importancia de de la
cooperación del en este caso la
capacidad militar que tienen ambos
actores no en lo en este caso En mi
opinión creo que en esta en este
proceder de de los cambios que está
teniendo el en este caso la política
internacional Creo que uno de los puntos
más importantes es seguir manteniendo
digo desde la perspectiva china seguir
manteniendo este vínculo sin ponerle a
lo mejor una etiqueta tal cual a la
vinculación con con Rusia sino que hasta
hoy en día ha sido y seguirá siendo eh
de alguna manera muy estratégico para
china mientras de alguna forma también
se reconfigura esta dinámica de lo que
es el occidente creo que hablar de
dicotomías como una cuestión tipo guerra
fría hoy en día este no cubre esas
características de lo que era el sistema
internacional en ese momento no Por lo
tanto creo que en en este sentido se
estamos frente a nuevos escenarios con
temáticas en las cuales este china es
protagonista y sobre todo creo que un
aspecto sumamente importante es como
también se muestra el mundo hace un
tercer mandato como un jefe de estado
que ha podido ir Avante a pesar de
muchísimas situaciones y creo que ese es
un punto importante hacia una nueva fase
en el tema de la política exterior china
Bueno y qué hay Raquel de ese
esa jugada de China a nivel
internacional de ser mediador en por
ejemplo en ese distanciamiento que había
entre Arabia Saudita e Irán Usted cree
que a futuro china se puede colgar esa
medallita de ser el gestor de haber
aportado en una pacificación en el caso
de Ucrania ahora que está
asumiendo este rol a nivel internacional
ante la ausencia de un liderazgo a nivel
mundial para buscar y unir posiciones
encontradas
creo que mediáticamente utiliza esta
esta dinámica o esto este logro que tuvo
no obstante creo que no podemos
calificar de la misma forma las
características de esa mediación a una
mediación muchísimo más compleja por
digamos todos los intereses que están
alrededor del conflicto ruso ucraniano
no en este caso los propios chinos que
están dentro de ese de ese conflicto
ruso ucraniano más todo lo demás de
otros actores que de alguna forma tienen
alcance a a nivel global no en no
solamente en la parte económica No
solamente la parte financiera sino
también en esta cuestión del
mantenimiento de paz desde una lógica de
alta política estamos hablando de
actores que dialogan en otro nivel
que no es el mismo en el que se dialoga
a nivel regional a lo mejor a nivel
medio oriente o a lo mejor en cuestiones
económicas Entonces en este sentido sí
mediáticamente es esa medalla que se
cuelga como para poder legitimar este
tipo de acciones o estos doce puntos no
obstante creo que el alcance de Quienes
son los que a quienes está mediando y
obviamente el impacto que pueda tener
esto no es el mismo a al de una una
mediación este a nivel regional Andrés
su opinión
yo creo que coincido primero con Raquel
y Estamos de acuerdo que esto no puede
evaluarse en términos de lo que se
concebía la Guerra Fría en su momento
estamos frente a una situación muchísimo
más compleja de transición Global en
donde hay una multitud de actores
interactuando en múltiples niveles y
esto hace muy difícil la comprensión de
cómo se produce la transición dicho esto
que es muy conceptual voy a bajar a
tierra voy a decir lo siguiente sí
después de la reunión o durante la
reunión
concreta la promesa que anunció
previamente de hablar con cdsky vamos a
ver que efectivamente Está tratando de
desempeñar un rol en tratar de
establecer algunas condiciones por lo
menos para un armisticio y eventualmente
para una negociación entre las dos
partes Putin señaló que él estaba
abierto a eso justamente en una columna
escrita en uno de los medios oficiales
chinos
también escribió los medios oficiales
rusos y Aparentemente esto tiene que ver
además con una intencionalidad muy clara
por parte de de China china está muy
interesada en preservar el mercado
europeo quiere mantener el vínculo con
la Europa desde luego un movimiento en
el sentido de facilitar un diálogo y un
avance de las negociaciones entre
Ucrania y Rusia ayuda desde luego a
consolidar la relación eventualmente con
Europa y no nos olvidemos que Ucrania
también es un socio comercial importante
de chile Entonces todos estos elementos
tomados en su conjunto y sumados al
hecho de que china quiere tener un
protagonismo internacional y lo ha
demostrado
iniciándose por el hecho de proponer un
plan de paz así sea que desde occidente
se le haya criticado muchísimo y desde
luego va a seguir en esta línea tratando
de de una manera insisto con mucha
prudencia con muchas cautelas
paulatinamente de ir impulsando sus
objetivos en política exterior y para
impulsar esos objetivos de política
exterior desde luego Rusia es un socio
necesario probablemente Europa también
pero Estados Unidos No necesariamente es
el socio están mirando con ojos de
cierto afecto ni Rusia ni chile
evidentemente sí parece que para Beijing
conviene más mantener las buenas
relaciones con la Unión Europea con
países como Alemania que es
importantísimo en la economía china más
que con Estados Unidos O por lo menos O
por lo menos
trata de mantener ahí la la relación de
buena forma con la Unión Europea ellos
ambos presidentes han hablado que están
buscando un mundo multipolar un mundo
mucho más justo pero que es justo para
Rusia que es justo para china en esto
coinciden o cada uno tiene una visión
diferente o esto es justo a la medida de
ellos porque todavía no hemos podido
entender cuál es ese nuevo orden mundial
que estaba tratando de provocar el
presidente Putin con este conflicto en
Ucrania Desatando la invasión y la
guerra en Ucrania ustedes lo entienden
lo pueden analizar Raquel comienzo por
usted sí creo que a nivel discursivo el
punto de encuentro en esta idea de Lo
justo es decir una gobernanza global
donde se incluya la perspectiva no
occidental que es como la gran crítica
de que pues prácticamente las
organizaciones internacionales se dan en
un contexto de Segunda Guerra Mundial
donde pues obviamente la dinámica o el
papel que hoy en día tienen China y
Rusia No necesariamente era el que hoy
en día está tal cual no Entonces en ese
sentido creo que es el punto de
encuentro en el discurso de ambos este
presidentes no y que eh silvin ha sido
muy enfático Durante los últimos años
con respecto a estas tesis del siglo
pasado con el liderazgo del Tercer mundo
no en el cual se toma en cuenta a esta
parte del mundo en la construcción de
gobernanza global no sin embargo creo
que de ahí se deriva a ya los intereses
de manera particular que puedan tener
Rusia y China y sobre todo cómo estos
dos jefes de estado que son muy
particulares que pareciera ser a lo
mejor muy Opuestos en en este en
determinación en Cómo se muestran a
nivel internacional de alguna forma han
venido a restaurar una idea de
nacionalismo y de reivindicación
histórica de ambos países dentro de la
construcción de la política
internacional actualmente entonces creo
que ahí ese punto de encuentro si lo
lleváramos a un nivel muchísimo más
abajo No necesariamente quiere decir que
sigan en la misma en sintonía sino que
es ahí donde parten estos este intereses
a nivel nacional y que de alguna forma
mientras funcione esta esta sintonía lo
demás se irá resolviendo en el camino
y cuál es su opinión en torno a este a
este entendimiento de un mundo
multipolar y un mundo justo cuando pues
estos dos países son señalados por
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos hay
violaciones
dentro de lo que considera el sistema
internacional hay persecución a la
oposición hay persecución a las minorías
hay muchas críticas en torno a estos dos
modelos que ellos intentan Mostrar
intentan vender al mundo
pero pero tiene sus problemas no estoy
diciendo que occidente sea perfecto y
que el modelo democrático o impuesto en
este lado del mundo sea maravilloso Pero
pero lo que ellos ofrecen tampoco se
vende tan fácil
a ver yo lo que diría es que
en realidad ni China de Rusia tratan de
imponer un modelo propio al resto de los
países esto es un dato muy importante si
consideramos la historia del
colonialismo para empezar justamente la
invasión en Rusia es porque querían
hacer un quiebre político e imponer Un
gobierno afina Moscú cercano a Moscú en
los términos de Moscú reporta toda una
historia que tiene que ver con la
expansión de local y con lo que se
inició en los 2014 con el euro maidan
Entonces yo lo que quiero señalar con
esto es una cosa importante por parte de
estos países y otros países del sur
global hay muchos agravios pendientes
con respecto a occidente cada uno de los
países lo procesa de acuerdo a su modelo
civilizatorio sus valores etcétera desde
luego no es lo mismo Rusia que china
Pero hay una especie de rechazo a que
occidente siga imponiendo la regla de
fuego y hay una aspiración a las
economías emergentes que se han
desplegado en los últimos 20 30 años
algunas de ellas como China
de eso es muy significativo al punto de
estar compitiendo con Estados Unidos
puedan tener algún tipo de participación
en la definición de las reglas de juego
Esas reglas de juego No necesariamente
son buenas malas son las reglas de juego
que aspiran cada uno en función de sus
propios objetivos estratégicos como país
y en ese sentido yo creo que no es
solamente el caso de Rusia o el caso de
China que estamos analizando en este
momento Si no hay muchos países del sur
global particularmente economías
emergentes de importancia que puedan
aspirar a una cosa similar y más que
concitarlas los países que están
incluidos en el grupo bricks ahora esto
no quiere decir la destrucción del
sistema con el sistema liberal
internacional como ha sido desarrollado
por accidente sino una corrección de
acuerdo a las aspiraciones de estos
actores algunos actores son más
radicales
otros son más pragmáticos y cautelosos
pero pareciera que hay un amplio
espectro de países y de Naciones
emergentes que aspiran a otra forma de
gobernanza global y yo creo que ese es
el punto donde tenemos que ver realmente
cómo actúa cada uno más allá de que
podamos ir consideraciones con respecto
a los derechos humanos o el derecho
internacional etcétera etcétera cosa que
se aplicable a muchísimos de los grandes
actores en el sistema internacional
históricamente claro y vale la pena
decir que no es que estemos vendiendo
aquí la idea de que occidente sea ya lo
dije sea la maravilla Es simplemente la
perspectiva que hay desde este lado
porque son las críticas que se hacen de
este lado pero justamente para eso están
ustedes acá para hacer el análisis de la
situación de allá para acá para entender
ambas caras de la moneda se me acaba el
tiempo Raquel Andrés efectivamente nos
quedan muchos temas que podríamos
analizar a raíz de Esta visita del
presidente de China
Moscú la visita sigue en marcha seguirán
saliendo conclusiones y el análisis Pues
nos puede
también se puede seguir extendiendo a lo
largo de los próximos días por los
diferentes temas que están abarcando
allí en Moscú pero sin duda alguna el
mundo entero está pendiente de lo que
decían allí los dos mandatarios de estos
dos países importantes para el ajedrez
internacional yo les agradezco mucho
haber estado con nosotros en el programa
gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 a ustedes Muchas
gracias por la sintonía En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos la
sintonía el día de hoy la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y de Luis Fernando Montes y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera ustedes pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con France 24
[Música]